we need to train I'm gonna teach you
everything I know starting with faith
this great cook will touch and death
anything you can turn to ash try to
figure out how to catch somebody we
can't touch you guys why better like let
you ran into a giant wooden wall cuz you
knit the next time you're out there in
your home you will win you like it / I
wasn't fast enough
hey youtubers it's Charlie touch a desk
so we got to talk about teeing up the
black flash on the flash
there's also legends of tomorrow stuff
that I'll address in this - there's so
many DC things that are happening during
the week now I add links in the
description just so everybody doesn't
miss the videos that I'm posting but be
sure to subscribe to get everything this
is a new round of the flash ring
giveaway that I'm going to be announcing
in my legends video that I'll post in a
couple hours so be sure to click that
Bell to enable alerts so you don't miss
anything
the really cool thing that's going on in
this is they're introducing a character
called Clive Yorkin he has very black
flash light power so it's going to tee
up the idea of the black flash draining
the life force from people like Clive
York and touches something it turns to
ash that's part of something called the
nephron process in the comics so he's
this mentally deranged person to get to
locked up in iron Heights because he's
found near the dead body of iris West
this is way back during the Silver Age
during the original Barry Allen comics
then way later in the comics after
crisis on Infinite Earths
he showed up in a Wally West title
inside iron Heights
right before a big gorilla grodd battle
with the flash the Wally West version of
the flash Barry on was still gone at
this time this is like way back I think
it was around 2004 when it's dropped but
the funny thing is is that in real life
the gorilla City episode is getting
ready to happen after this episode even
though there's a break in the flash next
week there's not supposed to be a new
episode but I'll remind people about the
schedule as we go along so the whole
idea here is that they have to find a
way to defeat him without touching him
so it's important for black flash fights
later on because you can't let the black
flash touch you but it's also important
for saving iris from sabotage because
you'd have to be fast enough like Wally
says at the end of the episode I'm not
fast enough so you probably noticed that
they'll Tia smaller ideas in early
episodes that will teach the hero a
lesson or give him some information that
will help him later on when he's
fighting the big bet you may notice last
year that Barry went back in time and
was talking to himself he learned about
time rates
I've never seen one of these until now
because you ran out of luck and time ran
hate it when speeds there's minutes late
the time line and now that seems going
to do everything it can to end you
he used that information during the
season finale when he was fighting zoom
who is now the black flash so I'll be
doing a video for legends of tomorrow
next so i'll explained that and i'm
going to try something a little bit
different where i just pick out like the
crazy scene in then do WTF moments so
that'll post in a little while but the
whole idea here is that they're training
Wally Wally has to learn these lessons
this is all from the Wally West era of
the comics so whole bunch of Wally
happening in the back half of the season
a lot of you have been asking especially
after the last episode if they're going
to push Grant Gustin out as Barry Allen
[ __ ] Barry on will die in Wally West
will take over as the flash just like
they did in the comics so the thing
about the flashes is that they all
signed seven-year contracts in Grant
Gustin is always going to be the main
version of the flash but there might be
brief period where he goes away in Wally
has to step up for maybe like a single
episode so I'm expecting to tease that
idea at some point but the show is it
such of a bummer that it would make you
think that the flash is never going to
come back they did the same thing with
the Oliver Queen character on arrow
where they killed him off seemingly but
you're like oh my god
Stephen Amell is the lead of the show
what are they going to do if there's no
arrow on arrow anymore
they have to bring him back so literally
in the next episode he woke up so to
speak so they let you know that he was
still alive so anytime the flash does
something like that they usually don't
let it sit for too long they'll let you
know what's going to happen like when
Barry got sucked into the Speed Force
and everybody thought he was dead but
really he just been turned into pure
energy he was visiting the speedster
version of heaven so we'll learn more
about that this season how much do you
know about the Speed Force the source of
my power so it makes me a speedster yes
and know when the first subatomic
particle sprang forth from the Big Bang
to form reality as you know it we were
there when the last proton decays stops
vibrating and plunges the universe into
heat death will be there too
I'm talking to the Speed Force isn't
that like saying having a conversation
with gravity or light or
so there might be a time when he gets
stuck in the speedforce for a brief
period between seasons I don't know if
they would actually be as bold to try
something like that but you guys can let
me know this episode seems like it's a
lot more about him than about anything
else do you think they're ever going to
do an episode where it seems like Barry
said so Wally steps up for a brief
period then Barry comes back because
they've been a couple times that that's
happened in the comics there was even a
really cool reverse flash story during
the Mark Waid era where Barry Allen came
back from the dead only to find out that
it was secretly evil Bart Don
masquerading as Barry Allen so there's a
whole bunch of reverse-flash stuff
happening on legends of tomorrow so I'll
talk about that when I post that video
but I'm really hoping for a couple of
big twists with the end of legends of
tomorrow because they're having all the
speedster stuff going on there's the
spear of destiny so if you guys aren't
watching that make sure you start
watching that because the way it's going
right now is I'm posting my flash videos
Tuesday nights then I'm posting the
trailer video then I'm posting legends
of tomorrow in then the arrow video so
hopefully you guys are able to find the
videos okay as long as you have alerts
enable for my channel you'll see the
videos when I post them every once in
awhile it takes a little while for those
to roll out YouTube breaks a little bit
but you can always go straight to my
channel page like the videos tab just to
see what I've been posting but it's
going to be great I'll be naming the
flash ring giveaway winner whenever I
post that legends video in a couple
hours so be sure to check that out where
you guys leafless a post you can click
here for my flash video and you can
click here for legends I'll add the link
as soon as that close - thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you in the next video